uh the experiences like that
um when I was going through the path
that experiences when I was experiencing
uh the world through other people's eyes
that experiences again like past lives
or like other dimensions where out of
body experiences yeah but then uh again
they're just content
that they're just content arising
through Consciousness uh fundamentally
no different than
anything that isn't remote viewing to me
just looking at you through the screen
is no different from like Azure
projection but then again they're fun
they're actually a lot of traditions
they focus on that as it means to get to
emptiness like dream yoga for example or
like practicing lucid dream and trying
to stay aware doing dreams or trying to
to be passionate dream yoga because in
those States you're it's a little bit
more uh less solidified so in a sense
the insights come easier doing dream
states or doing like you know out of
body experiences which again I think is
also why when I was going through the
path there were a lot of those
experiences it's because like my mind
was more valuable more malleable and
then I was doing a lot of inside
practices you know and my mind was more
concentrated so I was able to like
actually those days easier but then uh I
mean I don't really like try to access
those States anymore and they don't
really uh come to me as often as they
used to just because I I don't know why
I I guess going back to my theory or
according to my experience about how
most of those experiences are just the
byproduct of the dissolution of solidity
in the body mind once you're dissolved
those experiences unless you train them
which you can like I know Dana Ingram
which uh he calls himself an arha uh and
he is in our heart he does a lot of like
Casino fire Casino practices where it's
pretty much
um
I don't know exactly what it is but it's
uh it's basically working with like
clinical magic like so that's his way of
putting the emptiness back into the form
so
I would say after realization those
abilities will come way more easier for
you and if you don't train in they they
probably just won't occurred as much
so my way of putting empty this back
into form is just like
like weightlifting and like making
videos and things like that I don't
really do anything with my mind like
that anymore yeah
but maybe I'll do it tomorrow who knows
how would you instruct someone who's a
beginner to reach Enlightenment and I
put those in quotes on purpose and
what's the plan what's the path yeah I I
think if you it depends on where you
goal is let me I don't I I don't like
not everyone wants to attain realization
right some people just want to explore
Consciousness that's totally fine yeah
that's like just you know some people
like to play basketball some people like
to like you know play video games some
people like to take psychedelics or
meditate to attain different states of
consciousness
and that's fascinating I think that's
wonderful yeah but again like I said if
your goal is truth realization or or
Awakening that could be a very good tool
but that could also be a distraction it
all depends on like how you use them and
on context and stuff like that so it's
always good and bad everything's good
and bad to me the most magical thing is
your direct experience right now like
the is-ness just the fact that you're
conscious it is like the magic show like
you can't get any more magical than that
yeah just the fact that every moment is
like giving birth to itself every single
Moment Like I said earlier is is
manifesting itself that is already the
greatest magic show of all time how does
that even happen nobody knows
right so like whatever is arising within
this magic show like the magic show
within the magic show just isn't as
mind-blowing to me anymore it's just the
fact that I'm experiencing something
right now and I'm having a conversation
with you and all this stuff is like
surprising and then you're all of it and
none of it and it's like what the
that's for me is Magic
oh yeah the the answer you had a
question about Enlightenment right so I
think the best way to answer that
question is only Enlightenment gets
enlightened it's the same it's kind of
like the same thing as the magic there's
the magic show right it's like there's
no one here to gain like
only wakefulness wakes up to itself
that's the most direct answer I can give
you about why Enlightenment is
um because the ego can break in light
and again the the the point is not to
just to like kill the ego because you
can't kill something that wasn't alive
in the first place it's just to see
through a solidity that's another trap
that I want people to know is that you
you are seen through the cell as empty
processes happening you're not trying to
kill yourself
because at the end you know this whole
spiritual path is just about being your
most authentic self and your most
authentic self is empty
and the Paradox is to realize no self is
to find the self so higher self
and no self are actually just the same
thing